revista de prensa en directo américa de
france 24 hoy la mañana de miércoles
tenemos una revista de prensa especial
dedicada precisamente al diario la
prensa en nicaragua debido a su
persecución por parte del régimen de
daniel ortega casi ya la mayoría de su
personal pues tuvo que exiliarse debido
a la persecución política el
encarcelamiento algunos después sus
trabajadores y la imposibilidad de
trabajar en ese país debido a esta
persecución de los trabajadores de la
prensa de este rotativo rosa además de
con nosotros en el estudio rosa pues
empezamos como ya lo estaba avanzando
esta revista de prensa especial dedicada
a la prensa de nicaragua buenos días
raúl exactamente y precisamente como nos
comentaba a nuestro compañero
nicaragüense jorge gustado este es un
medio que está estrechamente vinculado a
las últimas décadas de historia de este
país al centroamericano porque se trata
del periódico más antiguo de hecho fue
fundado en
1926 y el que tenía mayo tirada cuando
tenía versión impresa porque como bien
comentaba este periódico ha sido objeto
de una creciente persecución política y
censura que se ha manifestado entre
otras expresiones en la retención
administrativa del papel que utilizaban
para imprimir el periódico y de hecho el
12 de agosto de 2021 no hace ni un año
publicaron su última edición impresa de
hecho la estamos viendo aquí detrás con
la siguiente portada la dictadura
retiene nuestro papel pero no puede
ocultar la verdad seguimos informando en
la prensa puntocom punto ni y con el pie
de portada sin test sin libertad de
prensa no hay democracia bien como
decíamos esta fue una censura que se fue
acentuando sobre todo a raíz de la
cobertura que este medio hacía de las
protestas que estallaron en 2018 pero
veamos algunas de las otras portadas en
las que denunciaban el acoso a este
medio de comunicación y en general el
recorte de la libertad de prensa vemos
esta portada en blanco no del 19 de
enero de 2021 se ha imaginado vivir sin
en forma o se nos agota la tinta pero no
las noticias del 25 de marzo de 2019
bien como comentábamos lo que esta
censura y esta represión y digamos la
hostilidad entre el gobierno de ortega y
murillo y pues la prensa como tal se
intensificó a raíz de las protestas que
estallaron pues a raíz de la reforma
contra la seguridad social de la
seguridad social pero que al final
acabaron pidiendo la dimisión de ortega
veamos algunas de las portadas que
publicó este medio en ese contexto por
ejemplo vemos esta de nicaragua esta
creíamos con una botella de agua en
honor a la huelga de hambre de las
madres de arrestados durante las
manifestaciones calificados de presos
políticos una portada del 21 de
noviembre de 2019 o por otro lado es a
la violencia orteguista ante la
resistencia ciudadana del 19 de abril de
2019 con esa cita daniel dictador
sandino se avergüenza criticaban anoche
a los jóvenes rosa y sin embargo son es
el primer episodio de dificultad y
represión que enfrenta este medio de
comunicación
como decíamos con fue fundado en 1926 y
desde entonces ha sufrido cierres
temporales indefinidos terremotos a
bombardeos arrestos e incluso el
asesinato de su director este medio es
siempre ha tenido una línea crítica con
el abuso de poder y las violaciones de
los derechos individuales y políticos
tanto durante la dictadura de la
dinastía somocista como durante el
gobierno de daniel ortega actualmente en
el poder no como curiosidad a este medio
a la prensa de nicaragua se la conoce
también como la república de papel fue
de hecho un apodo que le puso pablo
antonio cuadra poeta que también ejerció
como su director y que la bautizó así
república de papel cuando se cumplieron
50 años no de este periódico porque
alegaba que frente a un poder vertical
no de la dictadura feudal y déspota la
república sólo funcionaba en un pedazo
de papel que era así como somos había
calificado a este medio no como pedazo
de papel la voz del pueblo tenía su
curul o escaño en esa república de papel
este editorial de antonio cuadra bien
para que veamos un ejemplo de cómo
funcionaba esta crítica en distintas
circunstancias en el marco de este
terremoto que arruinó el país en la
navidad de 1972 en managua en que hubo
cerca de 20.000 muertos y que a raíz de
este terremoto se derrumbó la sede de la
prensa y hubo casi 70 días 69 días en
que no salió a la calle este periódico
digamos veamos la siguiente portada no
en 30 segundos solo hiroshima y managua
y critica el régimen de somoza de la
siguiente forma el terremoto fue un
ensayo del juicio final en sólo 30
segundos
el señor reclama su lugar como señor de
todas las criaturas que entre si deben
ser iguales y tratarse con equidad y
justicia y finalmente no veamos la
portada del asesinato de su director de
pedro joaquín chamorro cardenal veamos
el mandaron asesinarlo se considera que
este asesinato fue el evento que desató
la revolución sandinista no precisamente
más vemos la portada y de cuando
asesinaron a somos anastasio somoza
matan a somoza y finalmente para
terminar con este repaso hará una
cuestión a que ampliaremos sin duda con
a nuestro invitado es que también hay
una vínculo personal entre ortega y
murillo y la familia chamorro no
llamarlos a chamorro tanto violeta la
viuda
del director de la prensa que fue
presidenta de nicaragua entre el 90 y el
96 como su hija la conocida opositora
cristiana chamorro que se encuentra
actualmente encarcelada y por otro lado
rosario murillo vicepresidenta y mujer
de ortega trabajó diez años en la prensa
y algunos de sus excompañeros consideran
que ahí aprendió las tácticas que ahora
utiliza contra los medios de
comunicación después de toda esta
introducción rosa lo vamos a analizar
con nuestro primer invitado el día